Jordan Patel: Today’s focus: dark mode theming.
Avery Kim: Any blockers from last time?
Noah Williams: Let’s aim for a concrete owner and rollout plan.
Noah Williams: Risk: flaky tests for dark mode theming.
Samira López: UX needs a final pass on dark mode theming.
Jordan Patel: I think we split dark mode theming into two subtasks.
Riley Chen: Risk: accessibility gaps for dark mode theming.
Samira López: Let’s not block on dark mode theming; start with a spike.
Riley Chen: I propose we split dark mode theming into two subtasks.
Riley Chen: Action: set up dashboards.
Riley Chen: UX needs a final pass on dark mode theming.
Riley Chen: My take is we split dark mode theming into two subtasks.
Samira López: Action: write migration.
Avery Kim: My take is we split dark mode theming into two subtasks.
Avery Kim: Action: create test plan.
Samira López: Let’s not block on dark mode theming; start with a spike.
Avery Kim: Let’s not block on dark mode theming; ship a thin slice.
Samira López: I think we split dark mode theming into two subtasks.
Priya Singh: My take is we split dark mode theming into two subtasks.
Jordan Patel: I propose we split dark mode theming into two subtasks.
Avery Kim: Action: write migration.
Riley Chen: Infra-wise, Coordinate with SRE for rollout.
Riley Chen: Action: book design review.
Samira López: Let’s not block on dark mode theming; start with a spike.
Jordan Patel: Let’s capture action items clearly on dark mode theming.
Avery Kim: UX needs a final pass on dark mode theming.
Riley Chen: Let’s not block on dark mode theming; ship a thin slice.
Priya Singh: Action: write migration.
Jordan Patel: Action: write migration.
Noah Williams: From design side, Performance baseline needs to be recorded.
Samira López: Edge cases around auth and retries on dark mode theming.
Avery Kim: From design side, We might need a migration.
Avery Kim: Any risks we’re missing? on dark mode theming.
Jordan Patel: Let’s not block on dark mode theming; start with a spike.
Samira López: Risk: accessibility gaps for dark mode theming.
Samira López: My take is we split dark mode theming into two subtasks.
Jordan Patel: From design side, We might need a migration.
Noah Williams: Let’s clarify acceptance criteria on dark mode theming.
Jordan Patel: Any risks we’re missing? on dark mode theming.
Riley Chen: Action: set up dashboards.
Priya Singh: Risk: accessibility gaps for dark mode theming.
Riley Chen: I propose we split dark mode theming into two subtasks.
Samira López: Infra-wise, Specifically for dark mode theming.
Priya Singh: Risk: data migration for dark mode theming.
Avery Kim: Let’s not block on dark mode theming; start with a spike.
Priya Singh: Okay, who can take ownership?
Avery Kim: Let’s finalize target date in Jira after this.
Samira López: We’ll review outcomes in the next standup.